[Music]  okay so here's your rack of looks for  your party which one you want to try  first let's put on this great jacket  this looks like I live in England  there's nothing ridiculous  yay okay yay nay nay what are you  willing to wear to look really great at  your graduation party I'm not sure  enough I get contact dermatitis please  stop No stop being ridiculous  and this is not how I wanted my party to  go what did I do all this work for this  is a joke  we're a team and you are disrespecting  the people who are working so hard to  help no this is not my vision what is  your vision  David clearly didn't listen to it so  this is David's fault where are you  going I'm Soros hey he's Mazur we have a  round of club excuse me  that's it I'm done  [Music]  did he he just like walked out on us  right that's so annoying Spencer I mean  this is gonna be a complete disaster now  [Music]  [Applause]